hello and welcome to this video playing
12 stroke from Denmark let's play a
London system just for some variety okay
yeah happy to get the e5 square for the
night maybe I can set up something with
F for him mmm then it's normally not not
bad at all whoa okay 97 if I go teen
aged 5 let's let's do that here you will
probably have to play some pong move
okay Queen f7
yeah seems to be to not loose of Queen
f7 so okay I'm trying to use that pin
and maybe go look at three next
okay now he takes interesting okay um a
tick f7 take f6 there's lots of pressure
there I think it should be should be
good right if I just play for this
ending here look F 1 F 5g form that
should actually just win stuff
should win the f5 pawn okay let's also
see seven hanging but then possibly work
g8 so and got take here first now what
f5 seems to be how to defend anyway so
let's grab c7 so just Bishop takes on
anything better here get smoked check
let's take the second pawn yeah it seems
he wants to defend this position with
some the opposite colored bishops okay I
can do here I can go here though look at
that age seven porn
check
okay so I think Knight f3 Knight f6 mmm
I wonder maybe I should play this first
and kick him back so when I have success
bishop age for threatening 95 now you so
95 is another pawn hmm that's bad I
wanted to some are thinking look aged
aged 7 is working but of course it's not
night tix look slightly awkward even
though ik Bishop d3 of course so still
some trickery here
mmm the bishop comes to d3 this is not
not such an easy win actually but ok FB
should be five this is this is an
interesting ok just smooth if i can
trade my bishop against this night that
should be nice but now now is lucas is
really looking a little bit passive
there on g7 and i can bring the king of
going for h6 time warning check
check
check I'm promoting this now on you have
to come promoting check check black
resigns okay so I was a good outing for
the London system as I probably have
mentioned multiple times in earlier
videos i think that black should play
and something with c5 against the london
this is more more aggressive turn well
you can't do that yeah that's not bad of
course but you have to be a little bit
cautious not to drift into a position
that is a a tattoo passive and this
happened in this game yeah black is a
bit passive I think White's position is
easier to play this this no Queen age 5
m-f six I actually hadn't made there are
such a bad tactical player oh yeah it
looks bad yeah it looks bad and it is
bad I have my a checkmate let's mate and
in the shine check me so I had the hunch
that this look but I couldn't make it
work I couldn't make it work I should
have just thought about this for a
little bit a little bit at least okay I
wasn't so hard pressed because move like
this is also looking nice so were you
not but still I have to look at Bishop
87 here man okay
the way it went why its position is nice
but of course not made not made in three
and so I don't know I don't know how I
you should defend hit it's not easy at
all computer also Isis giving nothing
great here like a five which is doing
nothing basically what he played is
leading to chat to a very bad bad
situation here he just he just loses
loses the house him the game valuation
check but I'm still she and that I
didn't see that damn right just just a
maid yeah I think this is okay
technically he does not really have any
any defenses to to this yeah okay I'm
okay with what I did afterwards but I
still should play the mate okay thanks
for watching